You know, this is definitely a lesson I Learned way too late in life.
And now at 41, it is a um,
a rule I will stand by in my heart.
If there is a man, a grown ass man,
that needs that much help,
he got himself into that situation for a fucking reason.
Because this world was made by men,
created by men, run by men.
It is a big old boys club.
And girls are out here just trying to fight to stay alive,
literally to avoid violence and objectification.
So if there is a man that is like that hard up and struggling
and needs that much help,
he is a man that no one else wants to deal with.
He is probably violent, scary,
aggressive, and got to that place in life by his own doing.
So yeah, the girls that fucking get it,
get it. I will literally never help a man. Never.
I don't give a fuck. I don't give a fuck what position you're in.
I don't know who the fuck you hurt or why you're there.
And I'm not gonna put myself in danger anymore,
ever again. I'm like,
I've even told my boyfriend like this has caused an issue with us.
Cause I'm like, I'm a little bit terrified of men right now.
Like men fucking scare me.
This is like, I've had this shit happen to me when I was younger, teens,
20s, and now as a grown ass Woman.
To still have grown ass men acting this way,
it's the biggest. Like
grown men in these fucked up situations got themselves there.
They don't need anybody's fucking help.
And if they need help, another fucking man can help them.
It is not a woman's place to be helping a man. Followed that shit.